تتعاقب انتصارته اوكرانيا الميدانيه
فيرتفع لدى ساستها منسوب الثقه بامكانيه
حسم الحرب عسكريا غير ان تطلعات كيف الى
النصر لم تعد تصطدم بقوه روسيا وحسب وانما
ايضا بدعوات من حلفائها تطالبها بالتفاوض
مع الرؤوس والبحث عن تسويه سياسيه
انها دعوات تثير الريبه والاستغراب بل
وترقى الى حد مطالبه اوكرانيا بالاستسلام
يقول كبير مستشاري الرئيس
عندما تكون لديك المبادره في ساحه المعركه
يكون من الغريب بعض الشيء تلقي مقترحات
مثل لن تتمكن من القيام بكل شيء بالوسائل
العسكريه على اي حال فانت بحاجه الى
التفاوض ذلك يعني ان الدوله التي تستعد
اراضيها يجب ان تستسلم للدوله التي تخسر
انها اوضح لا اتي كيف واقواها مظاهره اولى
الدعوات الى الحوار وكانت بالاساس دعواتها
امريكيه ابرزها الاسبوع الماضي عندما
استبعد رئيس اركان الجيش الامريكي الجنرال
مارك ميلي قدره اوكرانيا على دفع القوات
الروسيه خارجه اراضيها بالقوه وعليه يتوجب
استثمار انتصارات كيف الحاليه
والاجهاك الروسي لفتح نافذه
لمفاوضات تنه النساء
ممارسه اي ضغوط على الجانب الاوكراني فان
محاولات ترويض كيف ترتبط في الكواليس
بمساع ان امريكيه للحفاظ على تماسك الدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا بعد تنام المخاوف في
اوروبا خاصه من اطاله امد الحرب
وتفاؤكم تاثيراتها الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه الهائله وفي مجبل الاحوال يجزم
خبراءوا في مراكز البحث ان لحظه الاحتكام
للدبلوماسيه ستاتي قطعا لكن ليس قبل
اوانها وحتى ذلك الحين يتعين على الجميع
السماح لديناميكيه الميدان
بتشكيل شروط التفاوض